what is the path to being worth 100
billion look like
there's a path to being worth 100
billion look like I don't know because
okay okay let me just like pause here 24
and there's so much awesome scaling so
many great ideas do you think about
different trajectories yeah uh what
those possible trajectives might look
like
yeah I mean if the goal was to just be
worth 100 billion dollars yes I'm my
goal I'm a broken record is to make the
best view impossible because I know
whatever else I want will come obviously
the video is the foundation yeah exactly
so to Pat to 100 million dollars is keep
getting 100 million views of video you
know what I mean
um but or more yeah or more exactly if
we can keep growing but you know if we
can
keep feasibles growing right and we
eventually spend International and one
day we're in 100 000 retail locations
and we're selling the same amount of
excuse or units per skews like we're
currently doing uh I mean that would
crush and then obviously ideally one day
we open up hundreds of Beast Burgers we
get it where we turn out you know like
supercell a couple hit games I don't
want to make dozens or hundreds of games
I just want to make games that are just
great and you know we rarely drop them
while we do they're bangers
um and just you know whatever other
stuff we end up doing all that combined
I mean it's just interesting because
like what what's a show that's pooled
100 million views per episode basically
it's like we're doing like you know I
mean like the Super Bowl gets praised
because they get 100 million viewers but
I can't think of a show
um maybe in reruns or something so
there's also a show that's has uh has a
singular kind of figure yeah that you
can now use as a like I don't have a
network tell me what to do I don't have
anyone like I can do whatever I want so
it's a very interesting position because
I put out content and 100 million people
show up and then I also have a gaming
channel I put out content 15 million
people show up in a reaction I put out
content 10 million people show up and
have a tick tock and I put out content
and on average 20 million people show up
and like and I so as long as I can keep
that going and then we build these
businesses it's like it's honestly
pretty scary to see what will happen you
know uh over the years because
feastables launched you know last year
2022 so it's a relatively new thing and
Beast Burger we just started scaling up
the physical side we haven't obviously
even launched any mobile games yet so I
think I'm at the antithesis of it I
don't see a world where my YouTube
channels are relevant in the next couple
of years I just this is what I live for
and so if I can keep that going and then
really start to expand these businesses
that leverage off of it then yeah I mean
hopefully there's the day one where I
could give away a billion dollars in a
video honestly that that yeah that would
be one hell of a video